i want you to think about we have two
different real estate companies here
okay
one of them has been flat for five years
straight and there's sales
the other one year after year after year
they keep beating their prior business
sales and it looks like this
i can tell you there's a lot of
different metrics people could say why
this person's flat and this person is
not
but there's one thing that's definite
they're doing a better job developing
sales people than they are and in
today's video i'm going to give you 11
steps on what you can do
to develop better sales people with your
company and prior to me getting into
this there are two episodes
i need you to watch as well so make a
note of it for you to watch us we'll put
in the playlist as well on the bottom
for you to find the links these are the
two the one on my right your left says
six reasons why you're not selling more
there's six reasons i'm not covered in
this video
but you need to watch it and have all
your sales people watch this
the other one is customer service versus
customer experience it is a must to
watch this as well
both of them are needed i'm not covering
this video so with that being said let's
get right into it
how to develop great sales people step
number one let me see exactly what step
number one is
this is very simple but most people
don't do it
when i ask somebody what they're looking
for in a partner a boyfriend a
girlfriend a husband a wife
most people don't even know what they're
looking for yet they want to find this
love of their life
it's the same exact thing when somebody
tells me my sales are flat and i ask
them the simple question
tell me what an ideal sales person in
your company looks like and they say
uh hard working uh
great attitude if you say uh uh too many
times you don't know what you're looking
for it's got to be very simple
take out a paper pen and write down
exactly
what the ideal sales person looks like
in your company you may say but i don't
know what that is
pick the best sales person in your
industry what does he do
that's the type of person you want go
look for people like that let me give
you an example
if i'm selling a product that is
a product let's just say you know i'm
selling perfume in the streets
and i run a sales shop i sell cologne
and perfumes in the streets it's a 40
sale i can have an 18 year old kid
selling that right i don't need a 43
year old person with a
degree and all this other stuff if i'm
selling private jets that are 5 million
and
up i need somebody a little bit more
sophisticated to be sitting in front of
them
to sell that now what if i'm selling
season tickets
to dallas cowboys or lakers games guess
what i need
i need to be able to sell the season
tickets i need to know a lot about
sports i need to be a fan i need to be a
love of the dodgers or the lakers or the
cowboys whatever it is if i'm selling
real estate
no matter what it is find out what that
ideal person looks like for your product
yours may even be they don't even need
to see them face to face because it's
over the phone
perfect what kind of a voice you're
looking for what kind of an attitude
you're looking for what's the tonality
but you need to get all that stuff in
place some of the qualities i look for
very simple number one i need audacity
audacity is what i look for coachability
is what i look for competitiveness is
what i look for so i kind of like it if
someone's played sports before in an
interview
i will ask have you played sports before
what do you think about sports the only
reason i'm starting a conversation about
support is because i want to know if
this person's got an opinion they're
competitive
i'm looking for that and then obviously
you're not really going to know anything
about work ethic
unless if you call references and unless
if you work with them you will learn
someone's work ethic within 30 60 90
days
but no matter what it is get a clear
recipe of what an ideal recruit
of a salesperson looks like for your
product number two how to develop great
sales people
a lot of times people come in and if a
sales leader doesn't know how to get
everybody started strong
early in the morning it's just it's
already starting on a bad note
so think about how most people start
their days they got into an argument
with their wife they're stuck in traffic
they got into an argument with their
boyfriend girlfriend
something doesn't go right in the
morning okay
they come to work they're already not in
the mood
you need to figure out a way how to
start their day better audio
a text a strong text a message a strong
motivational message in the morning in
your sales office if that's what's
happening as a sales organization
but you got to figure out a way to start
all the people
on a strong note on a daily basis point
number three let me give you point
number three
point number three is have a playbook
with scripts and faqs in your playbook
let me explain a lot of people will say
well i have my own way of selling things
no problem i want you to add your
personality to it but i need a skeleton
so just like all our bodies we have
pretty much the same amount of bones
okay we have the same skeleton in a way
skull but we all look different why some
of our bones are longer
some are taller some are thicker some
are big bone some are skinny some
are indome or ectomorph mesomorph but
regardless
we have the same skeleton then you pack
on the muscles the skin
the skin color the hair the nose all the
other stuff the skeleton
is the structure of the sales process
you have in your company the more
structure you have in your sales process
let me add the muscles i want to add to
my sales process which is my personality
when i worked at morgan stanley dean
wood on the script was whatever the
script was
i added a personality i would call and
say how are you doing listen i wanted to
share with you a new product came out
it's ice cream that doesn't melt until
you put it in your mouth and it melts
no way yes wouldn't you like to invest
into a stock like that would be amazing
john i'm just giving you a hard time
that doesn't exist i'm patrick b david
with morgan stanley dean witter at such
and such and such branch
the first part was to break ice that's
personality
then i'm given script so make sure you
have a playbook with scripts
everything in there that tells them what
do you say if they say i want to think
about it
what do you say if they say how much is
this what is if they say you know what's
the difference between you and your
competitor
have all those things in a manual so
sales person that comes in that's
hard-working
and it's somebody that's self-motivated
they're going to go through that manual
to learn for themselves
number four most effective training
in order i think 95
of sales officers do this part wrong
truly
95 of sales officers do this entire
thing
wrong let me give you an example and do
not be offended when i tell you this but
let me give you an example
if i go into an office and i see
the person that's the main sales guy in
the office is completely
out of shape and completely always
behind their desk
what's telling me is this is probably a
guy
that's constantly too tired too lazy to
get up and teach people the proper way
and he's probably somebody that just
sits as 50 people or is 10 sales people
whereas five sales people
in front of them tells them what to do
all the time and no one has moved
and no one's learning anything in order
of
importance where it's the most effective
way to teach
your sales skills to other people you
ready number one
a live sales appointment live sales
appointment
number two a live sales call for
instance
six or five new sales people there and
you make sales calls for a whole day
let them watch you speak your phone let
them watch you speak or make call let
them watch you let them watch you let
them watch you
if you give me two sales offices one of
them
trains their people like this for a
month straight
this person just talks talks talk stocks
it is not even fair on how
bad this office is going to dominate
this office because this person just
wants to tell people what to do
this one is actually showing them
setting an example on how to do it
so number one is a live sales
appointment number two is a live sales
call
then after that it's still not training
it's role playing
so tell me how you do it now give me the
phone can you do it now now you do you
tell me how you would do this present me
the appointment
how do you overcome the subjection what
would you say to this if they say this
what do you say they say this
have everybody in the office
role-playing each other to the point
where i remember one time i went to on
to an office sales office and it was a
new sales office that i had gone into
and i love this place because we added a
new culture to it this was membership
health club back in the days with ballet
total fitness
i added a culture to this office no
matter what
time of the day it is if a salesperson
walks by another person
and i say i want to think about it you
better have the rebuttal for it or else
it's five bucks
i'd walk past you hey i'm i'm not
interested in this contract do you have
a month to month
they better have something to say in
return if they don't have rebuttals five
bucks
it became so amazingly competitive where
everybody knew the words because we're
role playing all the time
so let me go back to the order of
importance on effectiveness
live appointment live sales call role
play
then a video i watch of your live calls
and live appointments so record a live
call and a live appointment get
permission that you can use it
and put it somewhere where all your
sales people can see that
and then it's a training and then
it's manual and then it's scripts
above all it's live always above all
is live next next
is this is the guaranteed guarantee that
someone's going to make it in sales
this skill alone guarantees that this
person is going to make it in sales
and too many times people teach this too
late and i always like to teach the
discipline of this early and here's what
it is
follow-up do you realize that if you as
a salesperson or you somebody that's
development
developing other salespeople if you get
other people
to master the art of follow-up early and
this is purely discipline
if you teach them the discipline of
follow-up early
do you realize you're pretty much
guaranteeing success with this person
here's why because i got two things here
one
i'm growing my pipeline of my customers
to sell
and if i have a hundred people to follow
up with maybe only to buy
then i got another 100 to add that's 200
now
10 by because the other now i got
another i'm adding my pipeline and i'm
getting it bigger
but because i'm teaching discipline to
my salespeople to follow up
everybody's following up and sales keeps
going higher
most of the time people don't teach
follow-up and what ends up happening
when you don't do follow-up is
oh this person's not interested next or
this person's not interested
next oh this person is not so you hear
these things that people say some will
somewhat so what
next yes that is true
sure some will somewhat so what next but
follow up
things change conditions change i've
called the client back six months later
when they had a death and a family
and they had six hundred thousand
dollars from a death benefit that
received from a life insurance policy
and we were able to help that person out
i've called people back that didn't want
to do business but they were okay with
me following up every 90 days
two and a half years later they did
business with me but i followed up
and eventually what they're looking for
the reason why follow-up is so important
let me tell you why follow-up is so
important
when i hear somebody follow up with me
every three to six months
and they do it for two three four years
guess what i see this person as
this person's a pro i like to do
business with people that are
professional
here's what i know most people will not
even stick around for two years in sales
and this person is still selling four
years later i'm doing business with you
because you're a pro
that's the pro this is why the
discipline of follow-up needs to be done
very very early next
constantly measure your sales people
so this is an element of accountability
and what i mean constantly
measure your sales people is daily then
it's weekly
then it's monthly quarterly annually the
way i like to do it
when i run a sales office anybody that's
in that sales office that i touch
i'm getting your activity on a daily
basis
on a weekly basis we do accountability
with everybody together
and based on behaviors and then results
let me explain if a behavior to me is
going to 19 networking events that's a
behavior
a result is i made six sales okay
if a behavior is 392 calls i made this
week
and i sold 28 products that's a behavior
and then i have a result
if my behaviors i got 49 business cards
this week
and then i close such and such behavior
result
i track behavior first and then i track
results and quite frankly
i am more concerned about the behavior
then i'm actually about the results
initially here's why
if i can teach and track the proper
behavior i
automatically know the results are going
to eventually be fine just yesterday i
spoke to one of the guys
and he told me the following thing when
i was speaking to him he said pat
when you were holding me accountable on
a weekly basis
i was making 250 calls a week ever since
you're no longer holding me accountable
on a weekly basis i'm only making 50
calls a week
because no one's holding them
accountable so there needs to be a
daily a weekly a monthly a quarterly
and an annual accountability system to
track them
and then as you're tracking their
numbers you're coming up with trends
to give them feedback you're coming up
with trends to give them feedback i do
this differently i do this differently i
do this differently
because you're giving them feedback on
how to improve number seven
create an environment with many tools
let me tell you
why i love tools i'll explain to why i
love tools okay
i can only individually train one person
okay i can in a small group setting
train maybe five ten people i can to an
audience speak to so many people on the
conference call so many people let's
just say
but tools are gonna work 24 7.
my body i can't teach 24 hours a day but
videos can teach 24 hours a day
audiobooks can teach 24 hours a day a
video on youtube can teach 24 hours a
day
an educational website can teach 24
hours a day a manual can teach 24 hours
a day
a website with faqs on it can teach 24
hours a day
and audio can teach 24 hours a day a
sales book recommendation
can't teach 24 hours a day a product
knowledge book
website video can teach 24 hours a day
but you cannot teach 24 hours a day
so you need to make sure your sales
environment to develop better sales
people
is an environment with a lot of great
tools that can be running 24 7
without you needing to be there that's
point number seven number eight
create a compensation plan that
gets me to work and gets me to compete
create a compensation plan that drives
the sales force for instance
we'll run many different sales contests
over the year just recently we gave away
hardy
uh a night brought special and we gave
away two uh
rolex presidential watches we'll take
our guys to dubai
and we'll rent out a yacht and we'll put
a contest on there or we'll do something
simple as an ipad
or an iphone or computer or a trip to
new york
or or something but there's always got
to be an incentive now you may say pat
i'm not that big to be running a harley
totally fine let me go back to when i
was small when i was small running a
small sales shop of five people guess
what it was
20 gift card to amazon it was lunch to
applebee's
then it was dinner to a nice place it
wasn't
it was a 50 gas card it doesn't matter
what it is it's your the top three sales
people are going to lunch together on
friday on me we're going to go have
sushi
it doesn't matter what it is you don't
need to give away harley in a rolex
presidential watch
it can be as small as a lunch with you
can be as small as a 20 gift card
to you but you got to make sure you have
a certain compensation plan
that creates an incentive for me to be
pushing more than the other guy
next one point number nine have a
leaders bulletin always a leader's
bulletin
a sales office with a leader's bulletin
that hasn't been updated for a day
is a dying sales office let me say it
again a sales office
without a leader's bulletin that's not
updated daily it's a dying sales office
somebody is too casual it's that guy
that sits behind the desk that's just
telling everybody what to do
but it's not driving this drives we
watch sports because there's a leaders
bulletin
golden globe emmys oscar all of that
people get excited because there's a
leaders bulletin and the academy
winner academy award goes to
and our next presidential de ghost tupa
and the mvp
and the championship and the triple
crown leaders bulletin
every office needs leaders bulletin
everywhere based on markers
you want to hit remember what i told you
behavior and result
so if you got a leader's bulletin that's
a behavior leaders bulletin for
everybody to see
who's leading the week and the cause of
whatever the behaviors you want great
that's one side
so i have a behaviors leaders bulletin
and i have a results leaders bulletin
and i want people to want to get on
every single one of them and everybody
sees their numbers especially throughout
the day so everyone knows exactly where
they're at
at any given moment number 10 number 10
announce sales contest now sales
contests are different than compensation
plan briefly i just explained to a
little bit of sales contest
but on the compensation plan side i want
tier compensation plans so
let me reverse both of them because that
one i explained in a different way
i want to i want a compensation plan
with tears
for instance if i do x y z i get a 5
bonus if i do such and such even more
than x y z i get a 10
bonus and if i do this it's a 15 bonus
it could be
if you sell 20 of this product this
month you get 100 bonus
if you sell 2025 it's 200 if you sell 30
it's 500 if you sell
40 it's a thousand dollar bonus you can
figure out your tiers
but create a compensation plan that gets
me to hit the next tier in the next year
next year it brings so much more sales
to your company last but not least
last but not least i love this one and i
think it's very very important
um teach ethical
sales practices early
a lot of times when when somebody would
come from another place that had sold
before
i i wouldn't know much about them
because they learned a lot of bad habits
from somebody else
i love teaching greenies in sales
because i can teach you the certain
ethics
that i will teach you that work in sales
too many times people are selling
at all costs close them up sell them do
this do this do that
at all cost even if they can't afford it
go for the throats there's a lot of
people that train all that stuff online
that's great for them i'm not selling
that way okay i'm not selling that way i
want quality business
because i want that person to keep
coming back and doing more business with
me and i want a lot of referrals from
this business to keep
person to keep coming back and do more
business with me very very important for
you to be thinking about that
when it comes down to you
teaching those ethical behaviors early
so one of the ways you could do it is do
what
charlie munger did raising his kids they
interviewed his kids charlie munger who
was warren buffett's partner still as
warren buffett's partner of
berkshire hathaway their kids with his
kids would say
every night we had dinner with that he
would always tell a story about somebody
that screwed up
big and what it cost them every night
charlie would tell his kids
mistakes of a great person that could
have been very successful that made a
mistake every night
so the kids were that there wasn't one
night that our dad wouldn't tell us a
horror story about somebody that made a
big mistake in their lives
you do that by teaching those bad
examples sharing those bad examples with
other people
here's why now everybody knows that if
they do it you already talked about it
so they won't do it that's one good
thing sometimes no don't talk about
because they'll do it no no
if you don't talk about it they will do
it because they're going to get creative
talk about it so they don't do it
because you've already put it out there
with everybody
and say this guy's courier ended early
because he did this that guy's corrie
ended early then
this guy's curry under it because he did
that but let me tell john that john's
been in business for 22 years
here's his life here's how much money he
made here's what he got here's how much
his clients respect on papa
he did that because he's building his
business based on the
proper career ethical practices and he's
been around the business and everyone
loves doing business with them
again it goes back to how you want to
build your company to me 11 is extremely
extremely valuable because a business
lasts a long time and you don't ever
want to have a reputation developing
sales people that are completely
scumbags and they're not ethical and
they'll do it anything at all cost
you just don't want that reputation
yourself as somebody that develops
people like that
so those are my 11 points for you on
what to do
to develop better salespeople with that
being said
paula let me get our pillow here from
jennifer mack
our new pillow if you got any questions
about today's episodes
episode comment on the bottom question
thoughts whatever you got
if you want to ask me a question you can
send me a message on snapchat my
snapchat should be right around here
david19 you can snap me and our goal is
to get to a million subs this year
and i think currently right now 170 778
subs and we need your help to help us
get it to a million subs in the next 11
and a half months
so please be sure to subscribe to this
channel by clicking over here
and also click the bell right next to
that you'll be one of the first
to be notified as a new video comes out
take care everybody bye
you